And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
You don't have a lot of questions that were submitted today,
so hopefully you guys have questions.
I'm going to be a short Zoom call.
All right, let's get started.
All right.
Just a reminder to everybody to look at the
member site for any new information,
anything new coming on board.
Also a reminder to make sure you look at the courses.
A lot of benefit to the courses and to new blog posts as well.
Got a couple of new people on it today.
You can use the chat on your Zoom to chat in questions.
So just chat in a question if you have a question
that you couldn't ask prior to the Zoom call.
Remember also to self-schedule.
If you need to do so, you need to talk to me specific.
Lee, when you get to the self-schedule thing
and you click on it, you will be given a choice
whether you want to just schedule a regular phone call
or if you want to schedule a Zoom call.
And the only time you really want to schedule a Zoom call
is if you're setting the labs and you want to go over
or that we got labs back that we want to go over.
Doing a Zoom call can be helpful
because then I can share my screen
and you'll see my pointer as I'm talking about this thing
right here, you'll be able to see what I'm talking about.
So I don't have to say CM page one
up or left hand quarter blah blah blah.
So doing a Zoom call to go over labs can be helpful.
All right, let's get started.
Curious about glutathione?
Should most breast cancer patients include this
with their supplement regimen?
I would say no.
So the pros and cons of glutathione.
So glutathione is your main, your primary intracellular
inside the cell antioxidant.
So you have processes of oxidation
and antioxidation going on in your body,
extracellally meaning outside the cell
and intracellally inside the cell.
So the glutathione is your main intracellular antioxidant.
It's made in the cell and you and it's,
and it breaks down oxidizing agents
that enter into the cell.
Now, whenever you listen and read about oxidizing agents,
you think of them as poisons or bad guys
things that oxidize cells can cause cancer.
So that's true.
So any poison or a toxin is an oxidizing agent
and it is, it's cancer causing,
it can damage cell membranes,
it can damage the nucleus of the cell
and if it damages the nucleus of the cell,
it can be a cause for cancer by oxidizing the amino acids
in the DNA, it can damage the DNA.
So oxidizing agents can be damaging.
However, there's a balance to that.
Everything in physiology has a balance.
Your body actually makes reactive oxygen species
for the purpose of killing biotoxins.
So when you have a biotoxin,
let's say you have a bacteria or a virus,
your body will make reactive oxygen species
to kill that virus or kill that bacteria.
So it's all about balance.
So remember that.
So I know we live in a world where you read a lot
about antioxidants and you should be taking
a lot of antioxidants.
Well, there may be truth to that.
Taking a lot of antioxidants can be helpful
because we're exposed to so many oxidizing agents
and pesticides, chemicals, heavy metals, toxins,
microtoxins, all these things are oxidizing agents.
So trying to balance out the amount of oxidizing agents
that are damaging their cell or have a potential
causing cancer with taking some extra antioxidants
can be helpful.
However, if you're trying to kill cancer,
you have to keep that balance that you're not
using too many oxidizing agents
because sometimes your body uses reactive oxygen
species to kill cancer cells.
That's exactly how chemotherapy works.
Chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent
and cancer cells tend to be more prone to damage
to oxidizing agents that a healthy cell does,
partly because a healthy cell is healthy
because the components of the cell are doing their job
and glutathione is a component that's recycled
within the cell.
So you don't actually need any exogenous glutathione.
A healthy person not exposed to excess oxidizing agents
does not need to take glutathione as a supplement.
Why?
Because glutathione is recycled inside the cell,
it's oxidized and reduced through a process
of recycling inside the cell.
So yeah, it does need the nutrients in order to do that.
And so taking some nutrients that can help that,
but typically an average person would get
that either diet as well.
So why would a person take glutathione?
It's all because they're realizing
that they're exposed to a lot of oxidizing agents
so they want to support the glutathione pathway.
Why wouldn't a person take glutathione?
If you're doing chemotherapy,
if you're doing another oxidizing agent,
like there's different supplements
that kill cancer through the process
of oxidization, protocell is one of those things.
So you don't take glutathione
when you're taking protocell and you gotta keep that balance.
So I only tell cancer patients to take glutathione
if it tests on the cheek swab that it's okay for them to take it.
If you're reading my book,
I'm not so positive on glutathione with cancer
because you are cancer,
cancer cells are more prone to die through oxidation.
And if you could actually be keeping cancer cells alive
by taking glutathione.
So I only recommend glutathione
with people that it tests well with,
otherwise I don't suggest glutathione.
And I don't suggest excess antioxidants
with cancer patients unless it tests well.
So lots of times in the natural world,
if you go to a natural path or a chiropractor
or some natural doctor who's reading literature
about other health conditions,
and then you have been a patient there.
So now you get a diagnosed cancer
and that person is helping you
but they don't really have a specialty in cancer.
They may put you on high dose antioxidants
and that might not be the right thing to do.
So there's some things that you would normally
that could be helpful for you
from a nutritional standpoint if you don't have cancer
and those same things might not be the right thing
to take if a person does have cancer.
So it was a very long 10 minute answer
to the question should most breast cancer patients
include this with their supplement regimen?
The answer is no.
And another reason is that you maybe keeping cancer
cells alive by taking glutathide
or you maybe counteracted an oxidative therapy
that you're doing either chemotherapy
or some nutritional oxidative therapy.
So the answer to this short answer is just no.
Lately, I thought I was taking too many supplements.
So I decided to take the estro clear,
aerobic clear and so four is I'm three times a day every day
and by osteopath and other osteopaths recommendations
and other vitamins every other day.
Do you see any downside for this?
So this person, I know the person who asked this question
and they are doing fantastic with their cancer
they would you could say they're in complete remission.
So I am all together and favor of doing this,
this would be called pulsing.
So pulsing your supplements is that you're taking some time off.
Maybe you take them five days a week and off on the weekends
or you could do it every other day.
Just like this, I think that would be fine,
especially if you're in a good position health wise
to do some pulsing.
Are there any vitamins you would recommend
that must be taken daily instead of every other day?
I think you're making the right decision
and I think we talked about this on a call.
These are things that you're taking to reduce bad astrogens.
So that would be something that you do want to take
on a daily basis.
Other things you could take, you could separate out.
But things you might want to take on a daily basis
are like in the summertime if you're sweating a lot
you might want to stay on minerals.
Things that you could pulse very easily
would be your fat soluble vitamins, your A and E and D and K.
Those are things that store well in your body.
Water soluble, nutritional things tend to not store well.
Things that maybe you'd want to take on a daily basis,
maybe you might make a decision based upon cold more abilities.
Let's see, I may have inflammation.
So you want to stay on anti-inflammatories,
the flavonoids on a daily basis.
Then I wouldn't suggest pulsing and doing this on somebody
that's, you know, is not going to clean bill of health
and doing great.
So stay to your protocol at that point.
Recently had good results with latest MRI.
Up here's resection margins are clean.
Now a tumor reduced in size from 10 centimeters
to 1.8 centimeters.
This person had surgical resection.
Plus suspect lymph nodes are now are not visible
of latest CT scan admittable on the MRI.
Getting another MRI next week for additional detail
based on radiologist recommendation.
It appears that the oncologist still recommends
four to six sessions of port based full fox
or just five FU.
I understand this is to weaken cancer cells
to prevent distant metastasis.
Yet this is also something that's going to weaken
the immune system and does not kill cancer stem cells.
When I ask they say it's all about the immune system.
It's not all about the immune system.
Thoughts on general on the chemo process.
I just don't want to take unnecessary risk
not sure what strategy is more risky either.
Okay, so my thoughts on doing chemo.
If you had a debolking procedure
where the cancer was encapsulated
and they're able to basically get the entire capsule,
no eat full well if there's probably circulated
tumor cells elsewhere.
That would not be a reason to do chemo.
Like if you have circulated tumor cells
there's no cancer.
Your PET scan is completely clean.
Should a person do chemo at that point?
Yeah, that's real questionable.
In this case, you know that there's still some cancer
that's present, it's smaller.
You know, there's still some there.
I would be more apt to say,
okay, I've gone this far to do the resection.
You know, I would be maybe willing to start
to do the chemo process and see how you do.
Remember, some people pedigeditically
on their detoxification pathways
and the health of their liver,
they could just sail right through this.
And, you know, they have been,
those are the people that have fantastic results
with the chemo and it did its job
because you were able to get it out of the body
before it was able to damage any healthy cells.
Now, you're gonna know that.
Well, the only way that you're gonna know
that you know that is to do one session at a time.
So, you know, of course I would pray about it.
Of course, I would give as much consideration as possible,
but I wouldn't, you know, completely rule it out.
So my opinion, you're getting multiple people's opinion.
My opinion, I wouldn't rule it out.
This could, you know, really put an end to the,
your struggle that you had up to this point
by doing maybe only a couple of sessions.
And maybe, maybe make a deal with the oncologist
and say, hey, I'll be willing to agree session
at a time here how I, how I do with it.
If I do well with the first session,
I'll move on to the second session.
If you'll be willing to take another scan
after three sessions, something like that.
I mean, that seems reasonable.
Because honestly, if you said,
well, why are you recommending four to six sessions?
The session, he's gonna say, well, that's,
the bottom line is, because that's what is recommended
by the pharmaceutical company.
They might say, well, that's what we've done
and we've had great results.
If you, if you pushed that and said,
have you ever done three sessions?
I mean, they wouldn't have an answer.
So the truth is, is that, you know,
90% of the people just do what they tell them to do.
So they don't test.
There is no test, whether only one session
is good or two sessions are good,
or who's, who came up with the four to six sessions?
The pharmaceutical company.
So there's nothing wrong with giving some pushback.
You know, hey, I'm willing to use my brain here
that yeah, some chemo could really knock down what's left.
But, you know, I'm the one that's in control of my body
and I'll decide when I want to stop
but I would like objective testing.
Are you willing to do another MRI or CT scan?
That's what I would say.
What are your thoughts on nicotine
and its effect on cancer?
Regarding cancer in inference on us,
can I go to a local tanning facility
that offers inference on us
or do I need to go elsewhere?
Your input is appreciated.
So this one, yeah, you can go to a local tanning facility
that offers inference on us.
That's just fine.
I don't see any problem with that.
You know, there's not toxins or anything
that you're gonna pick up at a local tanning facility
doing a sauna so I don't see any issue with that.
This I think is a completely separate question.
Nicotine and its effect on cancer.
While at first glance, I mean nicotine,
you know, is a major cause of lung cancer
and that's still the number,
I think it's the number one deadly cancer
is a small cell lung cancer.
But in truth, it's more probably the chemicals
that they put in tobacco and not necessarily the nicotine.
They put addictive forming chemicals in tobacco.
So tobacco today is very different than tobacco,
maybe back in the 1800s.
So tobacco is screened with addiction,
forming chemicals in order to get people
to be addicted to it to continue to buy their tobacco.
That is probably the most carcinogen aspect of tobacco.
So but in truth, nicotine is still probably
should be considered a toxic substance.
I don't think it should be consumed.
People will say, well, tobacco is just a natural substance.
I mean, it's God made it.
You know, I don't think we're supposed to smoke it.
Just because God made it doesn't mean we're supposed
to eat them, you know, so you can't use that excuse
with something that's consumed.
So, you know, I don't know if your question
really has to do with second-hand smoke
and it's affected our sarcoma.
I don't know if any studies are that.
I would definitely say that nicotine is a toxin.
It isn't good for anybody.
So but if it's, you're dealing with something
so but if it's, you're dealing with second-hand smoke,
it's you're dealing with a lot more toxins
than just a nicotine that's in that smoke.
So it's highly toxic substance.
Okay, questions from the chat.
We are needing to replace carpet in our house.
I've heard there could be some toxic outgassing
with new carpeting.
Damnity concerns, recommendations about new carpeting.
How to impact someone with cancer.
Well, there's definitely toxic outgassing
with all new carpet.
Carpet is obviously made with, you know,
as a chemical and many carpets are sprayed with fire retardants.
Can't remember the name of the fire retardant
but that is a major neurotoxid in itself.
And so yeah, you know, but you know,
going the round of a natural wool-based carpet
to be extremely expensive
and doesn't necessarily wear well
and it's not very state-resisted at all.
My son put in a, in their nursery,
he put in a wool-based carpet that was expensive
and it did not, it was horrible actually
as far as wear and state resistance goes.
It was just, it was just, they just said
it was just a big mistake.
So, you know, what do you do?
Maybe wait till the summertime
where you can open up all the windows
and turn the fans on and try to, you know,
get that stuff out of your house.
I can't remember who it was.
Some movie star years ago
I had a video of hers.
Herder has been had a son
and he ended up with a severe neurotoxic disease diagnosis.
They said he was betillary charted
at the tie with some strange neurotoxic disease.
They ended up detoxing him, going to actually
a higher proctor out in California did detoxing
the paragenetic desiology
and I would found out that he was a,
he was toxic with the fire,
the fire retardant chemical I believe
and some other chemicals did complete detoxing.
They tore all the carpet out of their house,
the sun got better and they wrote multiple articles
about it and living, trying to have a clean house.
So, a perfectly clean house
then would not include any carpeting
and would all be hardwoods or tile
and was that just not real practical?
I mean, they'll use throw rugs.
Well, the throw rugs have chemicals in them too.
I mean, it's just difficult to balance that out.
We certainly don't do that.
We have wall-to-wall carpeted areas of our house.
We have some wood in areas of our house
and obviously tile in the bathrooms
but yeah, it's a difficult thing.
I mean, some people are gonna have more issues with that
and it all depends upon different sensitivities.
It depends on if they have damage
to brain cells already and they have microglial priming.
They're gonna be more sensitive to those type of chemicals.
If they have compromised to the liver detox pathways,
they're gonna have a difficulty getting that stuff out.
They're gonna be more susceptible.
Just like people are more susceptible to different toxins
based upon the level of toxicity
that they're dealing with right now
and certainly if they're dealing with cancer
or some other, you know, more co-orbidity.
So yeah, you just have to find a balance.
Maybe it's like, okay, well,
we're just gonna do it in the summertime
and try to open the windows and leave the fans blowing
and try to just maybe get the carpets cleaned
even after we get them put in.
Always when you get your carpets cleaned,
you should clean with just hot water alone,
never any soap or chemicals ever, ever, ever
when you get carpets cleaned.
Their service is now that do that
or if you do it yourself,
right, to carp or cleaner or do it yourself.
Just with hot as water as you can possibly get,
I used to have a patient years ago
that had a carpet-cleaned service
and he just cleaned carpets with boiling water
and she's got great results, never used anything
but the stuff that he pulled out of carpets,
the cleaning solution that was left behind
from other cleaners was amazing.
So maybe try that.
That's another possible solution
to get some of that stuff out.
A couple of years ago, I had a doctor,
Rand DeMine, whose son is 12-year-old son
or something was having major neurotoxic issues.
I tested him, he tested positive for fire-retarded chemicals.
And I said, I don't know what this is,
it's fire-retarded chemicals.
Do you have any idea where he's getting that?
This was years ago before I knew anything
about really fire-retarded chemicals and he said,
well, yeah, we just got a brand-new pouch
and he's been sleeping on the pouch.
So all he did is change where he's sleeping
and all the symptoms went away.
Plus, he took some supplements to help detox it.
So these things can be major issues.
All the furniture you buy has that stuff in it.
All baby clothes have that stuff in it.
That's why my kids typically
buy this natural organic cotton baby clothes
even though they're more expensive.
You don't want to put that garbage on your little baby.
So yeah, it's just a matter of trying to strike a balance.
Do you test everyone for glutathyle?
My genetic test show problems with my glutathyle production?
Yes, I do test everyone for glutathyle.
So if I didn't put your glutathyle,
you shouldn't be on glutathyle.
So that's just my opinion.
My hematocrit is 33.9, range is 35 to 45.
Why is this low and what can be done?
Well, there can be multiple reasons
why your hematocrit can be low.
You'd want to look at that along with your red blood cell coat
and your other CBC values.
So I want to look at the rest of your CBC.
So yeah, you don't look at just one lot of value alone.
So you want to look at the rest of the CBC.
Should I have clarified, I should have clarified nicotine.
Nicotine therapy talks about nicotine patches
and possibly using organic nicotine SNUS
to help with cancer management reduction.
Your thoughts?
Well, I'm not familiar with that.
So I don't have an answer to that.
I don't know, I've not ever used that.
I've not even heard of that.
So I guess I don't have an answer for that, I apologize.
Something else to look into.
So red blood cells and hemoglobin are also on the lower side.
So then that tells us that you are quite possibly anemic.
So hematocrit is measures
measures the percentage of volume of red blood cells
in a centrifuge contents of blood.
So it's the part of the CBC that you look at the red blood cells
your hemoglobin, your red cell width
and such and your mid-corcoscular volume
and your serabaritan and your total iron-biting capacity
to help determine if you have anemia.
So if it's low, you could have iron deficiency anemia.
You could have vitamin B12 anemia.
You could have anemia due to blood loss.
You could have anemia due to increased destruction,
which is typically called anemia of chronic disease.
So anemia in cancer patients is typically
from what's called anemia of chronic disease.
So, but I think you have been dealing with
balancing that anemia issue for a time
and wasn't it you that increased your red meat consumption
and that helped?
So you need different nutrients to be able to make red blood cells.
You need to be able to support the production of red blood cells.
But whatever you have decreased red blood cells,
decreased hemoglobin and other factors of anemia,
you do want to look at, do I have bleeding issues?
Maybe it's because I'm a woman and I have heavy periods.
So I'm losing blood that way.
Am I making blood enough?
Am I supporting blood production with my diet
and my fasting too much?
And what else could cause anemia damage
because I did radiation and doing chemotherapy?
Oxidizing agents can damage red blood cell production.
So those of you want to look at causes of it,
make sure you investigate causes.
Many times with stage four cancer patients,
the cause really is that the cancer is just basically
gobbling up red blood cells and gobbling up.
Iured and hemoglobin for oxygen.
That's an oxygen carrying capacity of the blood.
And that's considered anemia of a chronic disease.
And then you're always with cancer, you're always like,
should I add Iured supplementation
because that could possibly feed cancer?
If I do that, I want to add artimisticated with it.
Or should I just, if I'm just kind of at that border,
should I just add more maybe red meat and beets
and foods that could help build blood back?
And that is always what you want to do
is your first step before you add Iured supplementation.
You also want to look at ferritid.
If your ferritid levels are high,
then you don't want to add Iured
because then you know you have an inflammatory process.
Remember I said B12 anemia can cause anemia patterns as well.
So deficiency in B12, and remember
your genetics also have defects on, you know,
MTHFR defects, MTR and MTRR defects.
Those are genes on the folate pathway
and the methydic pathway that can cause a deficiency in B12.
Plus if one commonly overlooked issues
causes anemia is a decrease in production in transic factor.
In transic factor is necessary for you to absorb B12.
So you might even be taking B12,
but you're not absorbing it
and you've got a B12 anemia because of that.
Well, why would you have a decrease in intrinsic factor?
The number one reason why you'd have a decrease
in intrinsic factor is hypochloridria.
So you have a decrease hydrochloric acid production in your stomach.
You need hydrochloric acid, you need an acidic stomach
in order to make it intrinsic factor,
you need an acidic stomach in order to absorb Iured
and to absorb B12.
So, and remember I've talked about this Zoom call
and some videos about hydrochloric acid
that is the number one issue worldwide
is especially in America because of our poor American diet
is damaged, the cells, the pridele cells of the stomach
that made hydrochloric acid in the number one problem
is a decrease hydrochloric acid.
It's a tanky hydrochloric acid
and concurrently digestive enzymes with each meal
can be the fix for anemia.
So make sure that you're taking HCl with each meal
and you're taking it enough,
many times people aren't taking it enough.
So, and with the size of the meal, you should take more.
So that can be the fix for anemia.
You know, it's talked to people that don't have cancer
that have suffered with anemia for decades
and just fixing their stomach
and hydrochloric acid production solves that problem.
And also, people could have, you know,
could suffer with symptoms from HCl for decades as well.
So, that's always caused from tie to hypochloridria.
So, look at that.
I actually have a video on hypochloridria
and HCl and everything on the blog post,
so make sure you look at those.
When I use chloroxygen chlorophyll,
the test comes good.
I don't know what you mean by that.
So, you take this product
and then you run a blood test and it's normal.
I'm not quite sure.
Not sure, not sure, in a pathway with that.
If that was true, then why don't you stay on that?
If that's solving the anemia issue,
might be affected HCl or maybe that's why.
I'm not quite sure, look, the metabolic pathway there.
Okay, any other questions?
All right, well, we will say goodbye for today.
Remember to get your questions in
or do like you guys all did such a great job today.
Chatting those questions in.
Thank you for another great day.
We'll get this up.
So, anybody can listen to it if they missed.
All right, God bless everybody, bye-bye.